the Joe Rogan experience did you ever
watch orange is the new black a couple
times is it any good it's not bad I just
didn't I felt like the characters were a
little too overt overdrawn I didn't buy
them as a real people too much they
seemed like it felt like a writer coming
up with a character as opposed to like
really trying to portray human behavior
but then again I've never been in a
women's prison my mom worked in a
women's prison for years dude really
yeah and she talked about they were all
Vic and we were talking about earlier
about you know women who were abused and
every [ __ ] one of them was abused
sexually physically almost all of them
are in jail because of a guy they were
carrying drugs for a guy
they say [ __ ] killed a guy because he
kept attacking her it was pretty rare
you know and a lot of it was obviously
drug use but that stems from usually
childhood abuse yeah yeah but that but
up for a lot of them my mom said it was
the best environment they'd ever lived
in because there was a solidarity among
a lot of the women there was a lot of
support there was education there were
support groups you know and and they
developed relationships with women
without men around mhm and so they were
able to foster a nurture real female
empowered relationships that's so sad
and cool at the same time yeah right
it's sad but it's like well it's nice
that something is working out for the
like women in jail seem did have a way
better time of it than men in jail just
seems like a better deal I think so you
probably not getting beat up as much
isn't there a new reality show about
women in jail with they're following
these women it's not just women most of
them I saw that's called jailbirds on
Netflix in Washington yes that's right
is that good or bad
yeah it follows them in like the
Sacramento Jail like the where they're
in holding her it seems like there's so
many [ __ ] shows about people in jail
that it must be like prisoners must get
agents now oh my like get off her second
off from MSNBC for lockup Greg they like
you but they'd like you to just get some
face tattoos do you think
you get you know they'll put you on yeah
hey Andy okay any bad guys show they're
giving us guys in jail Greg Fitzsimmons
I got on them we're giving you a
two-year option but I'm only in here for
one